unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
welcome everybody uh we're going to sort
of close out the cancun cruise
fiasco a little bit later in the show
but to talk about
sort of good things that came out of
this horrible situation
in texas we have a remarkable situation
in the united states
where a democratic new york
congresswoman
seems to be better representing the
interests
of texas residents than
their own actual republican u.s senator
ted cruz i'm talking about democratic
congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez as well as
texas democrat
beto o'rourke and other democrats who
came together
and while ted cruz was flying back and
forth to cancun mexico
appearing on the sean hannity program to
give conflict conflicting and bizarre
explanations
about uh exactly why he thought it was a
good idea at any point
to go to cancun in the midst of storms
and power outages afflicting his state
in the midst of all that alexandria
ocasio-cortez
took to twitter to announce a
fundraising effort
within two hours she raised three
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
by yesterday morning she and beto
o'rourke and others
had raised more than four million
dollars and there's a good chance that
by the time you listen to today's show
and watch this clip
she will have raised 5 million or more
dollars
for texas victims of these storms and
power outages
she also didn't just do online
fundraising
she actually went down to fill up food
boxes
at a houston food bank with uh
representatives
sylvia garcia and al green and sheila
jackson lee
and in the midst of all of this insanity
with texas politicians who voted against
hurricane sandy aid but that said give
us the texas aid now
for the power outages and flew to cancun
and back and said oh
the girls wanted to go on a trip
it is alexandria ocasio-cortez
supposedly enemy number one for a lot of
these republicans
who has actually put boots on the ground
for lack of a better term
raised money got food boxes together for
people unable to get food
and again when you are a texas voter
and you see that a democratic
congresswoman from another state
is doing more for you than your own
senator um it really should make you
reconsider whether you were represented
by the best people
and i sent out a couple of tweets about
this i tweeted over the weekend have ted
cruz greg abbott
and others thanked aoc for her huge
fundraising for texas victims of the
storms and power outages
as of this moment they have not but i
wouldn't be surprised
if at some point they sort of feel
obligated to put together some kind of
perfunctory
thank you to all of those who have
helped
us in our relief efforts also i tweeted
this morning
the texas fundraising story is crazy it
genuinely seems like
aoc and beto o'rourke haven't embezzled
any of the money
nor put their families on staff to
funnel cash to them
something that became basically standard
operating procedure
under the trump administration donald
trump putting
everybody from lara trump to who knows
who else on his campaign staff paying
them 180 grand a year
and so on and so forth now what just one
other side story with the insanity of
this
not only have aoc and beto o'rourke done
more
for texas than has ted cruz ted cruz
ended up desperately attempting a pr
uh photo op where he was putting uh
packages of bottled water
in the trunks and vehicles of texans and
it's like
there's no more pathetic attempt to make
up for his flying to cancun than
to be photographed handing out water but
that raised another question
why isn't ted cruz in quarantine right
now ted cruz
flew to mexico and then flew back the
next day
was he tested in mexico in the 20 hours
or 18 hours that he was there
do we know for sure that ted cruz is not
potentially
positive for coronavirus right now
shouldn't he be
and and absent a coronavirus test
quarantining right now rather than out
and about like
we may never know the answers to these
questions uh
and of course we were all asking wait a
second
he went he had kid ted cruz admits that
he had a bunch of his
daughter's friends over for dinner the
day before going to cancun
and then he went to cancun and then he
flew back the next day
is he being tested at any point during
this is he adhering to the protocols
about requiring tests to go to mexico to
come back to mexico by the united states
we just have no idea and we may never
even get answers to these questions but
they're questions we're not ignoring
is it some kind of exception for
senators i don't know
but we should be getting answers to this
and of course with ted cruz as with many
of these people
it's yeah sure these are the rules but
not for me
and uh that seems to apply unfortunately
to many of our leaders and it's not just
republicans that that's the case
with but we will talk a little bit more
about the ted cruz fiasco
later on we have to talk about joe
biden's biggest broken promise so far
now many of you might think i'm going to
talk about the lack of a coveted
stimulus bill so far
and that is quickly going in the failure
direction but we all knew that it could
take
some time to get it done i do think
enough time has gone by it's time to get
covered relief
done without republicans do it through
budget reconciliation
and we've been talking about that but in
any case what i believe
is biden's biggest failure so far is joe
biden's failed
promise on stopping the deportation of
undocumented immigrants through these
removal flights
that were prevalent under donald trump
until we can actually get
immigration policy fixed so first of all
what is going on if you haven't been
following the story
i understand you may not know what's
going on joe biden
promised to stop deportations until
immigration policy could be fixed now he
did
try via an executive order but
unfortunately a trump appointed
judge in texas quickly blocked the biden
administration's
executive order to do a 100-day
deportation
moratorium and the deportations are
happening just as they were happening
under donald trump last week ice carried
out
21 removal flights to six different
countries now it could be easy
for some on the left maybe you're
thinking this david hold on
joe biden did his executive order he
promised to do an executive order and he
did
and a judge blocked it biden tried his
hands are tied
sadly in this case that explanation just
isn't good enough
the judge that blocked joe biden's halt
to deportations
blocked it on very specific legal
grounds and joe biden could immediately
do
another executive order or even multiple
executive orders
with different justifications that legal
experts believe
would be far more difficult for a judge
to block
without getting into all the details
here the gist of this
is that because many of these
deportations are happening under what's
called title 42
that's an entire swath of circumstances
that could stop the deportations
because many legal experts and
immigration advocates believe that title
42 removals which are all
premised under the guise of stopping the
spread of covid removing people
to stop the spread of kovid many legal
experts and immigration activists
believe that
those provisions are under uh are
against
international refoulement laws that
they're not racially equitable
and each of these claims of course is
its kind of own legal morass
but the point is that it's not nearly as
simple as listen
joe signed an executive order and a
judge blocked it and that's it
i believe that there's a huge moral
urgency to do this
and if indeed it wasn't just one of a
list of calculated promises that joe
biden made
they need to just be cranking out
executive order after executive order
to get the deportation stopped it is
unlikely that there would be
uh legal mechanisms to stop every single
one of these
justifications and uh i believe that it
should be done now how much longer until
this is dealt with what is acceptable i
think that we are beyond it and so for
me this is joe biden's
uh biggest failure so far followed
closely behind
the slow progress on the coveted relief
bill which they need to get done
it it needs to happen today and if not
tomorrow and it should have happened a
couple of weeks ago
republicans don't want to play ball let
them vote against it
pass it via budget reconcilia
reconciliation i've been talking about
it for weeks now
but i am not yet calling that the
biggest failure i believe the
immigration failure is the biggest one
so far
if you disagree with me or you agree or
you're not sure
or you have some other failure that you
think is the biggest failure so far
let me know you can find me on twitter
deepakman and again
if you're just going to email me and say
david joe biden needs time
he promised to do this right away he did
the executive order it was blocked
many legal experts agree do another
executive order with a different
justification this can be done
how committed to it is the biden
administration we will soon see
find me on twitter at deepakman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation is one of the
biggest problems that our society faces
and online
filter bubbles make the problem worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first news comparison
platform that lets you compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021 with a
balanced news diet download the ground
news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we are a viewer and listener funded show
and you can support us by grabbing a
membership at
joinpackman.com don't be shy you'll also
get instant access to the daily bonus
show
award-winning awards we give out sure
but still many of those awards
have been won by the david pakman show
bonus show grab a membership
at joinedpakman.com so last week we
already discussed the story of
republican uh senator
from texas ted cruz fleeing the united
states for mexico with his family when
power outages
and major storms hit texas and ted cruz
who vote
formerly voted against hurricane relief
funding for hurricane sandy in new york
and new jersey
wanted immediate emergency funding for
what happened in texas
he asked for that funding hypocritically
and then fled
to cancun mexico to go to the beach now
because of the uproar
that it caused he cut his trip short and
flew
back to texas not even 24 hours later
and there are endless calls for him to
resign and you just have to see how fox
news covered it
to understand how these reactionary
right wingers end up
in seemingly alternate universes
imaginary alternate universes i think
it's important to say
it was a combination of pretending it
wasn't happening
what about ism and pretending that it's
just no big deal so let's look at some
examples here
first here is fox and friends defending
ted cruz and saying yeah but what about
andrew cuomo
55 seconds and by the way chris cuomo
who was allowed to interview his brother
in times of good back in the old days
he's not allowed anymore he's calling on
ted cruz to resign
right and yet not a word about his
brother who's
who's got the scandal on his hands it is
an amazing double standard it exposes
exactly who they are the pr
department of the democrat party uh
they're going after ted cruz because
he's been an effective
consistent conservative for years he may
have made the wrong call he acknowledges
that
but the media well they they they show
who they are every time
it does look a little lopsided over on
abc
all right i don't even know why steve
ducey
is talking about abc there i maybe i it
looked to me like pete heggseth was
attacking
cnn maybe i missed something earlier
about abc
i'm not sure but of course the playbook
is
ted cruz did something completely
indefensible and pathetic and
humiliating
well attack the media attack cnn
attack andrew cuomo attack attack chris
cuomo
but hold on this is about ted cruz why
are we talking about those other people
other approaches included coming up with
long forgotten scandals to resuscitate
like for example they went back to
hillary
they put up a headline on fox news about
quote
media and political elite mock trump
supporters
with a picture of hillary clinton
from a speech she gave in new york city
five years ago in 2016. this is not a
joke
they actually covered that as the ted
cruz scandal was on fire it reminds me
of the scene
from the movie the naked gun where the
great leslie nielsen
is saying nothing to see here please
disperse
as a building is exploding behind him
that's actually what they were covering
as everybody else was covering
the disgusting disaster of the absence
literal absence from country
of texas leadership during their storms
and power outages
and then while every network was
continuing to cover what was going on in
texas and what was going on with ted
cruz
fox news decided to run an explosive
story
about bill de blasio the new york city
mayor
supporting outdoor socially distanced
dance performances in new york city
during the pandemic okay so
that's fox news's coverage of ted cruz
on fox news now
understand that some other networks and
some other right-wing shows
and other right-wing media outlets they
didn't even talk about
it at all fox and friends went in on
defending what ted cruz was doing
that's one approach but there were many
who were just talking about other things
they were talking about
uh you know joe biden and his dog which
we will get to a little bit later
and all sorts of other non-stories and
we are seeing it before our very eyes in
real time
the sort of fermentation of
germination of maybe what is likely to
be the approach from right-wing media
for the next four years and we
we've predicted it we weren't unique in
predicting it that right-wing media was
going to be particularly crazy and
weaponized in part because
you have more rep competition right now
in this right-wing media space than you
had four years ago
for who can do the most cartoonish
crazy coverage to get away from
criticizing anything the right does
or to find new ways to criticize
anything joe biden does and we are
seeing it and we're going to have some
more examples a little bit later
but let's now get to an incredible
interview
that ted cruz gave to sean hannity and
that's what i want to discuss next
okay so let's now get into
the it's not even really a maya culpa
interview that ted cruz
gave to sean hannity on fox news because
he doesn't really say he did anything
wrong
other than saying i realized i
i think he says like as he was getting
on the plane to go to cancun convenient
time to realize it
that maybe the optics of the trip
weren't quite so good so
let's get into ted cruz's various
explanations
for the misguided trip to cancun last
week again to reset the story for you
texas gets hit with storms and cold
which causes power outages many
republicans try to blame frozen wind
farms for the power outages that's wrong
most of the problem with power with
electricity supply in texas was caused
by
frozen instruments at nuclear power
plants
at natural gas power plants and at coal
power plants yes some windmills froze
mostly the problem was the fossil fuels
and the nuclear
and of course the reason for this is not
because wind farms and nuclear and coal
and gas
can't produce power in cold weather
it's because texas even though a decade
ago
had a similar power outage and got a
report saying
here's how you winterize all of these
types of power generation
they didn't do it so that's why this is
going on okay
so um here are ted cruz's explanations
for why in the midst of all this
he decided to go to cancun and then come
back first
relatively early in the scandal ted
cruz's office put out a statement
basically throwing his own daughters
under the bus saying quote with school
cancelled for the week our girls
asked to take a trip with friends
wanting to be a good dad
he just wants to be a good dad everybody
with wanting to be a good dad i flew
down with them last night and i'm flying
back this afternoon
now unfortunately the decision to fly
back
quote this afternoon was not the
originally scheduled
trip of ted cruz he changed his ticket
to fly back
immediately 20 hours after landing
because the story exploded
and we know that ted cruz went down
there with a bunch of luggage
we later learned he had a flight booked
not for friday but for the weekend so he
had to change his explanation once that
got out he had intended to stay
for several days uh cruz had the amount
of luggage i bring on a 10-day trip
and he wanted us to believe it was a
20-hour trip so that one imploded very
quickly
then ted cruz is interviewed at the
cancun airport
on his way back let's take a look at
that video
last night dropped them off here and now
i'm headed back to texas
and back to continuing to work to try to
get the power of what's happening in
texas is unacceptable that a lot of
texans are hurting
the valiant and brave public servant
heading back from a 20-hour trip
to get the power back on wait a second
it wasn't even a vacation he was
basically just chaperoning the flight
down and he was going to work remotely
okay
so then ted cruz upon returning to texas
agrees to do
the big interview with fox news
propagandist sean hannity to really
clear the air
and get back on the in the good graces
of the american people
it starts with sean hannity sucking up
to ted cruz so right after
we saw this we knew it wasn't going to
be a real interview and you were fully
and completely engaged and i know that
from my own reporting and my own
conversations with you and governor
abbott and with joe bastardi
so a priori before the interview
sean hannity already has cleared ted
cruz of wrongdoing
great for ted so then hannity keeps
doing it keeps it going
and says listen you can be a senator and
just make a quick round trip to cancun
i think you can be a father and be the
senator of texas
all at the same time and make a
round-trip quick drop-off trip and come
home
well sean that's right and and hannity
uh
barely stopping short there of i would
be worried
if you weren't going to cancun in the
midst of this senator what a hero and
what a great father you are thank you so
much
okay so finally it's ted cruz's turn
and he goes into his explanation our
house was dark we had no heat
actually the fireplace behind me we were
all huddled around the fireplace
because it was the only heat in the
house and and
after a couple of days after the girls
being really cold at being in the teens
and the 20s outside our girl's ass said
look
school's been canceled for the week can
can we take a trip
and go somewhere warm and and heidi and
i as parents we
we said okay sure and so last night i
flew down with them
uh to the beach uh and then i flew back
this afternoon i had initially planned
to stay
through the weekend and to work remotely
there but but as i
as i was heading down there you know i
started to have second thoughts almost
immediately
so notice there that ted cruz because he
was outed as having a return
a round-trip ticket where he wasn't
coming back until the weekend
he had to say i initially planned to
stay through the weekend which is true
but he realized he really should be in
texas by which he means i got caught
the blaming of the daughters is
hilarious too and i was thinking like
what kid demands to go on vacation the
next day
to mexico and gets the okay from their
parents like growing up for me
and all of my friends vacations and
trips were planned in advance hey mom
and dad let's go to cancun
tomorrow like in 12 hours sure let's do
it i'm just trying to be a good
dad this was simply escaping a bad
situation
in the united states and fleeing across
the u.s mexico border
that way south for a better situation in
cancun that's all that this was
and then one last clip which is really
funny in continuing
to explain the cancun trip ted cruz
casually mentions that a lot of his
daughter's friends were over for dinner
there's a pandemic going on what are you
doing having multiple kids over from
multiple households
tonight we had a bunch of kids at our
house because our house was one of the
few houses that had power and so we had
a lot of our daughter's friends were
over we're making dinner for them
and right about i don't know 6 6 30 boom
the lights go out and we lose power
and so we had a candlelight dinner
because that's all we had we had
flashlights and then the girls all
camped out they got in sleeping bags and
wrapped up in
in uh in comforters and everything and
then we flew to cancun
and it was all great sean truly truly
great so
a big explanation from ted cruz that
quite frankly explained
nothing other than what we thought which
is ted cruz continues to live in his own
world
and when the outside world got into his
life he lost
power he decided to flee across the
border
to the country of mexico he should
resign there are many calls for his
resignation
he's not going to resign we'll have more
coverage of this
on our instagram at david pakman show
by the way if you want to see what
happened to my hair
thanks to the wind over the weekend
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
it's bizarre and it's probably not
something you want to let children
see it's really a uh it's it's a
it's a hair disaster for lack of a
better term quick break back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
so cnbc has this host joe kernan who's
been around
a very very long time we've talked about
him before he's previously attacked me
on twitter and he sometimes will do
really cringey interviews
on cnbc some of which we've covered in
the past
and the last few days were no exception
to that
joe kernan invited on an independent
energy consultant
named allison silverstein to talk about
what happened
in texas with the storms and the power
outage
and it sort of seemed like joe curnan
was being
moderately reasonable during the first
part of the interview
but when alison silverstein starts to
assert her expertise
in a way that joe kernan doesn't like
for political reasons like for example
saying
even if we continue switching over to
renewable energy to green power
a week in winterize it can be resilient
it can work fine in all sorts of
different weather
it started going downhill slowly slowly
slowly you see the frustration build for
joe kernan
where at the end he ends up doing almost
like
the full prototypical unhinged
flat out climate science denial
bury your head in the sand type stuff so
we'll build to that we're going to pick
it up where allison silverstein is
explaining that
the reason the grid lost power
generation capacity was because as we've
now talked about many times
talked about it last week talked about
it earlier today texas
opted not to winterize many elements
of their electrical grid including coal
natural gas and nuclear plants and yes
some wind turbines despite the fact that
they were advised to win to rise
a decade ago when they had similar power
outages caused by
um cold weather and uh alison
silverstein also criticizes
the isolated nature of texas's grid and
so
let's start there so that we're all on
the same page as to how this started
going in this bad direction for joe
kernan
there was all of this happen because of
insufficient power plant
winterization this was a guideline it
wasn't mandatory
there was a huge chunk of the natural
gas supply for texas power plants that
froze
up both at the wellhead level at
production and
in pipelines so gas plants couldn't get
the fuel that they needed to run
ercot under forecast customer demand by
20 percent
which means that they didn't have enough
generation ready to
serve customer demand that kept rising
as the night got colder and colder
and last er cuts a standalone grid so
they were unable to
alleviate these shortages by importing
gen
electricity from outside from the rest
of texas
and that's a wonderful idea if you like
avoiding federal regulations but it's a
terrible idea if you like protecting
reliability
against disasters like this so that's uh
sort of sets
up her view and in the second part of
this interview
it starts to go downhill even after joe
kernan
initially concedes that those initial
critiques of wind power
and frozen windmills weren't true alison
silverstein
makes clear that listen big picture even
if we switch over
more and more to renewable energy it can
be fine in the winter
it's okay and that's how it starts to
get wacky
well you pointed out that the i forget
what type of energy you caught it but
the more conventional energy natural gas
and others that you talked about did
were affected by the cold just like you
know we're
you know initially certain people maybe
the governor
maybe uh you know people that that
aren't big
aren't big green new deal proponents
said well you know
the windmills froze and the sun went
down and or went away so you didn't have
solar
or wind um that wasn't true
but because we now know that the the
conventional stuff was affected by
the cold as well but what about
renewables and and the future that we're
looking at
will will we be ready
for adverse weather events if we're uh
if we're
much more dependent on this this new age
renewable energy of course we will
and the the thing is what
grid reliability requires that you
understand the resources that you have
so joe starts to get a look of
on his face because alison silverstein
says
of course we will be ready for weather
events under a renewable energy system
and then by the end of it it's full on
climate denialism
with joe kernan repeating some of these
silly things oh oh they said it was
going to get warmer but the warmer can
make it cooler and none of it makes
sense and it's all just silly take a
look
and and um we can make a bridge much
more stable with more efficiency
but i mean there have been cold spells
before
in texas this was similar to one of what
back it how long ago was it about
35 2011. right i mean it's 2011 and
in 1990 1990 as well so
you know i i mean it's kind of a big
leap
we did not implement all of the lessons
like whenever it is
used to just be cold air from the arctic
now it's a polar vortex caused by the
warming
so i i need to see the i need to see the
peer-reviewed science on the
on on the uh the warming causing the
cold anyway
allison so do i but the point is
that the weather every kind of weather
is getting worse
right and and so we need to plan we need
to plan a system that suits
much more kinds of really horrible
weather
and part of part of improving
reliability in a different system is
more transmission
thank you bye okay thank you alison we
appreciate it
so the takeaway here is that anything
short of total absolute simplicity in
the eyes of a committed climate denier
means that they can just write off the
entire thing as completely untrue
and of course you may know and we've
been reporting on this for a decade at
this point
the climate data on this has been
understood for a very long time many
decades
what was originally sometimes called
global warming which is not
inaccurate when you talk about an
increase in global temperature
really it's climate change and it can
include
yes an overall warming of the earth
it can include an overall warming of the
oceans
on earth which by throwing off the
balance of the environment
can cause acutely hot and cold spells
in individual places over periods of
many different years that is
understanding how climate and weather
are two different things but joe kernan
either doesn't get it
or doesn't want to get it and takes any
opportunity
where nuance is required to say oh give
me a break uh
it's global warming which causes it to
be cold
oh it's a polar vortex come on guys it
must all just be completely fake
climate is the extended circumstances
over time and place the whole planet
might warm by two degrees
the oceans might warm by two degrees or
something hypothetically
and then in terms of weather that can
cause
lots of high temperature records and low
temperature records
in different places it could be extra
cold in places that are often warmer
you could have milder summers in places
that are typically hotter
you could have more hurricanes or
tornadoes or whatever drought
as another example and unfortunately
this is how much of the climate
denialism system works oh you used to
call it global warming
but now it's too cold in some places so
you change the name
checkmate liberals this is the level on
which they're operating
if the oceans are warming why is it so
cold in texas
checkmate liberals come on and
the saddest part of this is that that
type of of talking point that type of
denialism
is really well suited for the party of
anti-science which has decried college
education
as merely liberal indoctrination for a
decade now
and although we're making progress over
time on more and more people
understanding reality more and more
people conceding that
yes human activity probably does play a
role in our changing climate it is a
very slow process
and in the meantime people like joe
kernan
can do a lot of damage by making the
progress on public opinion on this
even slower and that's exactly what he
is trying to do pathetic
we've seen this from joe kernan before
no indication he's going to stop anytime
soon
if you want to see how deep
and long-lasting the current republican
party
delusion or lies depending on what you
think about them
about the 2020 presidential election are
going to last i have very bad news for
you
it looks like the denialism delusion and
lies about the 2020 election are going
to last
for a very long time i have video for
you from yesterday
of top house republican steve scalise
he's the house
minority whip or whip as some say
he went on abc's this week he was
interviewed by host
jonathan carl and asked a very simple
question
are you ready to say the election wasn't
stolen
are you ready to say that donald trump
didn't really win
in a landslide as he claims and that joe
biden simply won
he got more votes in enough states to
get more than 270 electoral votes
steve scalise is asked this question
listen to the equivocation
listen to the language choices of steve
scalise
this is almost march we are almost
four months from this election and steve
scalise just won't stop
but clear this up for me joe biden won
the election
he is the legitimate president of the
united states
the election was not stolen correct
look joe biden's the president uh there
were a few states that did not follow
their state laws that's really the
dispute that you've seen continue on and
look
if you're joe biden you probably want to
keep talking about impeachment
and anything other than the fact that
he's killed millions of american energy
jobs
that is a 29 second clip half of which
is and the anchor talking
and still in 15 seconds steve scalise
manages to slip
in look joe biden is the president
which is that's a sort of dog whistle
that's code for
he is the president but he didn't win
understand the careful vocabulary
choices there
scalise says there were states that
didn't follow
their own state laws by which he means
too many people who wanted to vote were
able to vote and nobody stopped them
with the voter suppression that we were
planning
and then he says joe biden would rather
keep talking about impeachment
no he wouldn't joe biden hasn't been
talking about impeachment
since being sworn in every time biden is
asked about impeachment he says
i'm not involved i wasn't in the senate
when this was uh
done i had nothing to do with the house
vote i'm not getting involved
since impeachment joe biden also hasn't
been talking about it joe biden seems to
have no interest in talking about
impeachment
then it continues and jonathan carl
tries again
to get a straight answer that he
continues to
they just signed the paris accord it's
going to kill manufacturing jobs in
america
but at the end of the day when you look
at where we are in this country
either we're going to address the
problems that happen with the election
that people are still millions of people
are still concerned about the
constitution says state legislatures set
the rules for elections
that didn't happen in a few states and
so going forward
look joe biden isn't it but doesn't it
but i i mean i mean
towards what people are angry about but
but congressman i know joe biden's the
president he lives at the white house
uh i asked you is he the legitimate
president of the united states and do
you concede
that this election was not stolen very
simple question please
understand once once the elect once the
electors are counted yes he's the
legitimate president
but if you're going to ignore the fact
that there were states that did not
follow their own state legislatively set
laws once the electors voted
he's the legitimate president but and
and of course
there what he means is the electors
in some states voted for the person who
didn't really win
in some states biden got the electoral
vote
but he hadn't actually won the popular
vote in those states these
are the continued dog whistles there's a
little bit more let's take a quick look
at it
that's the issue at heart that millions
of people still
are not happy with and don't want to see
happen again you know look
you can rehash the election from 2020
all day long
but there are people concerned about
what the next election is going to look
like and we're going to finally get back
to the way the rule of law works and i
think that's the biggest frustration
many people have is
those states that didn't follow the law
are they going to keep doing that in the
future
are we going to finally get back to what
the constitution calls out
for electing our leaders imagine saying
as steve scalise a ranking republican
says that what people want with
elections
is to get back to the rule of law
despite
democrats trump lost claimed victory at
2 a.m on election night
ran a two-month campaign claiming it was
stolen
and that he won in a landslide had
lawyers
try more than 50 legal complaints
none of which went anywhere still
refused to concede
and then incited a riotous insurrection
at the capitol on january 6 and steve
scalise says
we need to get back to the rule of law
we'll talk to your own party
talk to people like josh hawley and
others
it's just stunning and then um oh
it's separately from this same interview
the topic of january 6th
does come up and jonathan carl points
out
trump still hasn't taken any
responsibility for
his role in inciting that riot check out
the mental gymnastics
scalise does here just as difficult to
get an answer on this one
but but wait a minute i mean he hasn't
taken responsibility you heard kevin
mccarthy say i mean do you agree with
what kevin mccarthy
said there that the president must take
responsibility that the facts
demand that he take responsibility for
what happened on january 6th
well first of all i wrote a wall street
journal editorial about
where i think the responsibility lays
for january 6th and surely there's a lot
of
blame to go around but at the end of the
day the people who stormed the capitol
on january 6th
it was a disgrace and they need to be
held accountable in fact over 180
have already been arrested and i know
the fbi is working to root out every
person
who broke into the capital who attacked
police others i mean that's
that's obvious i'm asking about donald
trump's
role in this you heard again kevin
mccarthy do you agree with what he said
that he bears responsibility for what
happened for what happened again you can
go back
you can go back and look at the
impeachment trial the the second
impeachment trial it seems like
all they've done since they walked into
office was try to impeach him but
again when you look at that trial they
ran a clip of pretty much
every united states senator who voted to
impeach president trump
who talked about things like go and
fight like kell and
other things like that even the simplest
of questions
he will not answer if they would put
any kind of blame on donald trump
he simply won't do it and steve scalise
is
remaining as one of the most steadfast
defenders of donald trump
absolutely no matter what period end of
story so
the message is if you thought they'd
stop defending him any time soon not so
and the reason we care about this is not
because we need to be reminded again
that these people don't care about law
and order
and don't care about the truth or
reality or facts or empiricism or the
world as it actually exists rather than
as they wish that it would be the reason
this matters is that
if they still won't even concede that
trump actually did lose
they aren't going to be um anything but
complete and utter obstructionists for
the foreseeable future
which reinvigorates my thought that it's
time to stop waiting on republicans for
covet stimulus
it's time for democrats to pass it via
budget reconciliation let
every single republican if they want
to vote against it and put themselves at
risk of the electoral consequences
if their uh constituents don't like it
but these are the people we're waiting
around for
the guy who still won't say trump had
something to do with the insurrection
and still won't say
trump simply lost these people can't be
counted on for anything and it's time to
just move forward without them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right so i have a a perfect video
clip for you today
to illustrate one of the biggest ruses
that exists on fox news in the past
when fox news has been criticized for
their outrageous cartoonish right-wing
political bias
they'll often say listen we have our
opinion programming just like any other
network and sure
some of it is is right-wing it's
conservative it's pro-republican
but we are also a news station and
during
news hours we are right up there with
the best of them in reporting
just the facts just the news now without
even looking at today's clip which i'm
going to get to in a moment
understand that fox news deliberately
has blurred
the lines between news and opinion for a
very long time for as long as they've
existed and also not that this is their
fault due to terrible media literacy in
the united states
much of their audience doesn't realize
what is news and what is opinion
fox news also does something where they
will report on what their opinion hosts
say during the news hours as if it's
news
so tucker carlson one night might say
something insane
on his 9 p.m show and then the next day
the news hours we'll have
a news report about
tucker carlson said this here's a panel
to discuss
it so even they are able to take their
own opinion
programming and put it directly into the
news
segments so this news versus opinion
distinction has been nonsense from day
from day one but then we have this clip
to play
of news reporter bill hemmer
from the news reporting side of fox news
during a news not opinion show
called america's newsroom saying we've
got to be careful with this cancel
culture stuff because the next thing you
know they're going to cancel
bible characters take a look at the
video clip
i tell you if they start canceling these
american presidents they're going to
come after bible
characters next yeah you could you could
mark my words
right an ominous warning from bill
hemmer
that the cancel culture liberals are
going to
cancel bible characters if we allow them
to continue
for some reason the inclusion of mark my
words at the end is particularly
hysterical i was sort of chuckling to
myself
because as ridiculous and silly as this
is at least bill hemmer is calling them
bible characters rather than historical
figures now i don't know if that's his
intention i don't know if we can read
too much into his perspective from it
but it is funny and
this is lowest common denominator type
stuff
this is what happens when you aren't a
victim
and your audience aren't victims at
least in the ways they claim to be much
of the fox news audience are victims
of uh deficits to our educational system
uh victims of the power of elites and
corporations and so
okay fine but they're not victims in the
ways they claim to be victims
and the political interests that they
represent
aren't victims either they invent a new
victimhood
the war on christmas was the fabrication
of victimhood
donald trump as the most unfairly
treated person
in the world or whatever it was he
claimed to be that's
fabricating victimhood with trump it was
almost like fabricating martyrdom
even and then the saddest most
horrifying part of it
is that a significant portion of the
country i don't know the percentage but
it's it's a significant number
sees this and says yep that resonates
with me
that's a concern of mine that's the
battle that's my battle
that fox news is waging here that feels
like something really important they
might
cancel bible characters uh and it
ends up being the horrible situation
that we have of course
the entire cancellation meme that they
won't stop with
is as pathetic as any specific example
but they've started to get attention
with the cancel culture stuff
and so they're going to ride it for as
long as they can let's do
our best not to fall for it there are
some people on the left
who fall for the cancel culture stuff
and of course
we can all find instances of wrongful
termination
or misapplication of terms of service on
a platform
but let's not feed into this false
notion that
everything is just unfairly canceling
conservatives who merely want to
get their opinions out there no we've
talked about it before
i'm glad to rehash it again if necessary
that is not what is going on here we
shouldn't allow ourselves
to feed the notion because they will
just take it and
this is what you end up with i'll tell
you they're going to cancel bible
characters if we let them keep doing it
no
it's not happening the uh tan suit type
fake scandals about joe biden are
quickly ramping up
last week we covered tucker carlson's
explosive reporting
about how supposedly joe and jill biden
don't really love each other
their marriage is merely a stage managed
public relations strategy that was last
week
this week we have a clip from newsmax
host
greg kelly saying that joe biden's
choice of dog
isn't very presidential referring of
course to the biden's
senior german shepherd champ and
bringing on a panel to discuss this
important topic
saying biden's dog looks like he's from
a junkyard
check this out did you see the dog let's
get i want to show you something i
noticed
doesn't he look a little a little rough
i love dogs but this dog needs a bath
and a comb and
all kinds of love and care i've never
seen a dog
in the white house uh like this i
remember buddy i remember millie i
remember lots of dogs but not a dog who
seems
i don't know i don't know how much love
and care he is getting let's bring in
the historians
i i'm having fun with this obviously but
i i do want to talk about some stuff
craig shirley reagan biographer
presidential historian greg
welcome back and doug weed presidential
historian former advisor george h.w bush
that's the white house where i remember
millie millie had
like a staff and they really took care
of her very beautiful dog
this dog looks like from i'm sorry from
the junkyard and i love that dog
but he looks like he's not been well
cared for no
not not at all thank you for having us
uh
no he looks very dirty and disheveled
and uh very unlike
a presidential dog like millie or
victory or
something else in the past and the pres
in the white house
this isn't the right type of dog
for the white house trump didn't have a
dog
trump seemed unable to understand a
thing about human dog
relationships a junkyard dog
which one of the so-called presidential
experts brought on to the panel to
discuss this
says was a disheveled and dirty dog
this is obama's tan suit redux
but extra stupid because it's not even
about
biden it's about biden's dog this is
obama's mustard choices are bougie
again joe biden has the wrong type of
dog
for the white house and the dog doesn't
look right and look at what they are
doing
they have a panel on which craig shirley
a presidential historian says champ
looks very dirty and disheveled
and very unlike a presidential dog do
you really need
an historian to tell you that or maybe
you could get just one of the people who
held one of those 10-foot trump flags
in palm beach florida on president's day
i don't know that you need an expert
if this is the type of opinion that
you're looking for another
manufactured right-wing scandal these
during presidential administrations of
democrats
these completely imaginary right-wing
scandals
are as certain i guess as death and
taxes death taxes
and tan suit type scandals now
was this a deliberate deflection from
the ted cruz fiasco that was going on
i don't know are right wingers against
rescue dogs now
it has to be a designer dog from a
breeder to meet their standards and to
be suitable for a president as far as
they're concerned
this is more confirmation about how
different
these two sides of american politics are
i'm the first to say
on many issues democrats and republicans
are too similar
there's not enough daylight between them
but we've talked about
real policy differences and when it
comes to substance versus fluff
under barack obama the scandals were tan
suits
mustard types that type of thing under
trump
it was hey what about the emoluments
clause what about asking foreign powers
for help getting re-elected
what about putting the u.s on the road
to authoritarianism those were the
concerns
now joe biden is president and it's joe
and jill biden's love is
fabricated and joe biden has the wrong
type of dog
who's dirty and to be clear there are
already serious critiques of joe biden
but they're not the ones that right-wing
media wants to make
as i've been saying for weeks what is
going on with coveted relief
that's a real question joe biden said
right away checks are going out it's
almost march there's still no deal
that's real
biden said he would stop deportations in
order to figure out
what to do about immigration he did one
executive order a judge blocked it and
he's done nothing else
he could do more executive orders we
talked about that in detail earlier
today
there are criticisms of joe biden
they're not the ones
that fox news oan and newsmax want to
make
and the desperation of the right wing
to make any democrat look bad is
pathetic if you have to insult a dog
you're really hitting rock bottom and
these people are truly
and completely disgusting we have a
voicemail number that is 2192davidp
that number is available anytime if it's
2am
and you've got a hankering for leaving
me a voicemail
you can do it at 2192 david p
here is a caller as i unders this is a
complicated voicemail i believe that
this
is a white caller who is mad
that uh he is hating white people
because of left-wing shows i think
that's what he's saying
and there's also a cat in the background
second only
to having the david pakman show playing
in the background when you leave a
voicemail
is having an animal making noise in the
background let's take a listen
hey dude uh
i'm i'm calling this good i wanted to
ask
i mean do you realize that that i'm
probably not one of the only
but you're actually not your show
in itself but you're radicalizing the
left
in in a certain way you know what i mean
because
i feel like being like it
the the rotten that you show
in the efforts to show how rotten the
the right is
which they are it's all white people
i don't want to hate white people i'm
half white myself i'm half white half
black
but god damn man i'm done with this man
i'm done
with these crazy ass white people always
doing bull
and talking
it's ridiculous man it's dumb
like i can't stand these people like i
laughed
when i heard that that that
preach some love somewhere i i don't
know
is this person upset with me is he upset
with what he believes or
disproportionately white
actors in the republican party which of
course would be accurate
is the cat upset with him that won't
stop
making noise in the background i don't
really know what to make of that call
it's very interesting but i i truly
don't know what to make of it maybe
someone can explain it to me
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
citibank wired 500 million dollars by
mistake
and a judge says they can't get it back
very interesting story
after an engine failure
dozens of boeing triple sevens have been
grounded
in the united states and japan and there
is some very
interesting backstory here and we will
talk about all of it on the bonus show
and lastly there is a teachers union
that is now saying let's reopen schools
if the nfl could figure out how to do it
let's do it now of course the nfl also
had
very particular resources when it comes
to testing and other things
which it's unclear school districts
would have but it is a very interesting
shift we are seeing from
some school districts it will be a good
opportunity
to review coronavirus numbers to look at
deaths hospitalizations vaccinations and
many other things
so all of those stories and more
happening today
on the bonus show get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com it's quick
it's easy it's painless it's cheap and
you can use the coupon
code better21 to get a powerful discount
off of the membership of your choice
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you then and we've got a great week of
shows coming up for you this week
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground